tildado de genio como de blasfemo el
escritor salman rushdie nacido en bombay
y en la india en 1947 y nacionalizado
británico y estadounidense ha tenido una
vida de novela acomodado desde la cuna
estudió en uno de los mejores internados
de reino unido más tarde obtuvo una
maestría en historia por la universidad
de cambridge con especialización en
temas islámicos en la religión de su
familia una religión cuyos líderes lo
repudiaron en los años 80 la razón su
libro los versos satánicos considerado
una blasfemia por los seguidores del
islam el entonces ayatolá jomeiní de
irán emitió una fatua o decreto
religioso que puso incluso precio a su
cabeza
rusty nunca se ha arrepentido de su
novela
realmente no pienso en eso la novela ha
sido maravillosamente recibida en todo
el mundo y eso fue puramente un gran
evento literario vio el éxito la
recompensa para quien lo matara superó
los 3 millones de dólares y la polémica
no ha cesado con los años más aún tras
ser investido caballero del reino unido-
en india o pakistán
protestas masivas
las autoridades de irán nunca le han
perdonado su atrevimiento estoy en eso
premiar a una persona que se encuentra
entre los personajes más detestados de
la sociedad islámica es una prueba
evidente de anti islamismo por parte de
altos funcionarios británicos son la
persecución que ha recibido durante su
vida le ha llevado a ser un gran
defensor de la libertad de expresión
tampoco en este punto le ha abandonado
la controversia activo donde si solo
defiende la libertad de expresión que se
ajusta a tu propio marco moral esto es
lo que normalmente se llama censura su
voz tenía que haber sido escuchada este
viernes en el estado de nueva york la
censura la ha intentado callar a
puñaladas